merci d'être avec nous au pire charron
après un week-end évidemment polarisé
dans l'actualité politique par le plan
de bataille de nicolas sarkozy un plan
de bataille que thibaut enoch nous
raconte avec les réactions qu'il a
suscitées y compris dans votre propre
camp je me suis engagé dans une longue
route et nicolas sarkozy est de retour
mais pour quoi faire exactement je suis
pas venu pour expliquer que je serai
candidat à la présidence de la
république en 2017 pour l'elysée en 2017
quoi qu'il en dise
mais avant je suis venu pour créer les
conditions d'une alternative crédible
qui rassemble des français bien au delà
des clivages habituels droite gauche
pour créer un grand rassemblement à la
de gaulle en somme nos querelles d'ego
sont stupides
première étape donc le parti qu'on me
lise comme président et vous allez voir
que nous allons créer un enthousiasme la
méthode tout changé nouveaux projets
nouveaux modes de fonctionnement mais
sur le projet justement nicolas sarkozy
dit peu de choses
une ligne politique pragmatique les
seules propositions concrètes réforme de
schengen recours au référendum sont
reprises de la campagne de 2012 en ligne
de mire toujours les électeurs du front
national je veux aller reconquérir ces
français mais pas question apparemment
de promettre une rupture radicale comme
certains à l'ump
mais pourquoi cette expression brutale
thérapie de choc comme s'il fallait
trépané les gens les rivaux justement
nicolas sarkozy semble vouloir les
amadouer alain juppé est un partenaire
et un ami et un compagnon
c'est quelqu'un pour qui j'ai même de
l'admiration et j'aurai besoin de lui
mais sur sa route
ils seront bien le principal obstacle
françois fillon
je n'ai pas le culte des sauveurs et
alain juppé qui tous deux ont redit leur
détermination
je souhaite bonne chance à tous les
candidats nous avons tous besoin les uns
des autres je pense que la droite et le
centre doivent se rassembler
redonner un espoir à france 2
chacun à notre manière et avec notre
style et contribue au moment où nicolas
sarkozy s'est exprimé
l'ancien premier ministre a même publié
une ébauche de projet hier soir sur son
blog pierre charon enfin enfin l'enfant
prodigue de la gloire napoléon vous
connaissez l'ajaccienne là il y avait
dans la jante et oui oui les revenus on
espérait tous ceux l'association des
amis s'étaient créés dès lendemain de sa
défaite
mais sa défaite qui était honorable
parce que grâce à ces propos à la
mutalité ce soir là où j'étais au
premier rang en larmes
évidemment il a donné un espoir tout de
suite je me retire je me retire je me
retire adieu mes amis mes rayons très
beau discours le discours de la
médiathèque franchement après c'était
préserver l'aura perdu peu comme nos
arrières oui est-ce que les élégants à
l'aide à peu près perlant comme giscard
avait empêché de la ville télé nous
empêcher de oui il a été très élégant
d'accord mais quand il dit encore hier
j'ai perdu de si peu il a perdu
exactement comme valéry giscard
d'estaing avait perdu face à françois
mitterrand on n'a pas l'impression que
ça oui c'est un peu ça se joue quand
même assez rarement à huit points de
différence c'est vrai mais là lorsque
giscard veut revenir ou ou chirac
ils sont à 15 --les 8 à 25 déjà
c'est-à-dire qu'il accueille dix points
de plus on voulait revenir que ceux qui
voulaient revenir à juste titre
d'ailleurs
voilà alors ce retour les commentateurs
disent alors évidemment c'est les fusée
à plusieurs étages on a quand même assez
bien compris mais en même temps il ya
une forme de contradiction qu'on a
essayé de 2,2 montré tout à l'heure dans
tel ou tel domaine
ses propos sur le mage pour tous par
exemple c'est que à la fois il faut qui
clivent et qu'ils y aillent un peu fort
pour resserrer son électorat et en même
temps le discours qui vient c'est je
vais je vais bouger des lignes je vais
faire
quelque chose qui va rendre sur année
les clivages hier on n'avait pas
l'impression que les clivages était susi
suranné que ça je pense pas il ya eu
plusieurs temps hier soir comme vous
l'avez vu dans cette émission de 45
minutes dans un premier temps il a dit
je n'ai pas changé je moi je pense qu'il
n'a pas changé et j'espère qu'il n'a pas
changé mais voilà j'ai réfléchi j'ai
réfléchi ou qu'ils aient pu heurter j'ai
pu pour parfaire le texte d'accord hier
ça s'était assise par auto critique ça a
duré 2 minutes 30 dans la contrée ce tir
et les bagues après après on est passé
aux choses sérieuses la lgv est élevé ce
genre de choses et je laime comme ça moi
j'ai retrouvé j'ai vu c'est un des jours
le sarkozy de 2007 c'est dire celui qui
a faim celui qui veut y aller ce qu'est
l'énergie en 2012 j'étais pas d'autres
jeunes gens plus ou moins arrogant et
ambitieux qu'il y est non l'est là les
vieux compagnons sont là tout le monde
est là les jeunes les nouvelles têtes
il a tout à fait raison de le faire et
en même temps il ya ceux qui connaissent
nicolas sarkozy qui sont des joueurs de
sa génération et je pense qu'il est non
seulement le meilleur de sa génération
mais il est le meilleur de la génération
suivante puisque parmi tous les jeunes
qui arrivent rue de miromesnil ou dans
la future structure
visiblement ils n'ont pas choisi d'être
candidat contre lui à partir de ce
moment là c'est bien qu'ils aient une
primaire au sein de l'ump pour la
présidence de l'ump et qu'ensuite il est
dans sa dot le le pouvoir de changer
l'ump c'est ce que nous souhaitons tous
ce que tous les adhérents se fait ça et
après on fait le rassemblement thème
gaullien thème gaulliste j'adore ça
renouveau rassemblement c'est ce qui va
faire
oui mais encore de gaulle revient il
revient pas pour postuler à la
présidence d'un parti c'est ça quand
même et on se doute bien que nicolas
sarkozy n'avait pas dans sa tête
jeudi il a un drôle de destin sarkozy
parce que quand il prend l'ump la
première fois c'est parce que super est
empêché à cause des affaires il prend il
va reprendre l'ump la deuxième fois
parce que copé est amplifié par des
affaires c'est son destin comme celle
opérée posez vous oubliez un truc c'est
quand sega démissionne il prend aussi le
paradis présent
et la tête pour les pour les élections
dans le heureusement qu'ils ont pas
porté bonheur
non je n'étais pas du tout prévu de
prendre l'ump il prend l'ump pourquoi
parce qu'ils lâchent ils les chicaillas
long terme basque qui arrive dans cette
affaire montre qu' il peut pas laisser
le parti comme ça ce sont des mini
écuries qui s'apprête à se sur la
gueule je suis en 2010 et il prend ou
sans révéler parce que ses deux rivaux
fillon et jean pévèle à une erreur
tactique terrible mais c'est d'abord à
l'abandon la question de la présidence
de l'ump
c'est une porte qui l'ont entre ouverte
dans laquelle nicolas sachant qu'un ses
choix ce sont nos amis comme l'a rappelé
prison sarkozy hier soir mais a avec le
gré de crédibilité totale et concurrents
nous autres reviennent non mais quand
juppé promeneurs et un conflit dur si
sarkozy abandonne les primaires ça vient
de tomber
oui action ben je pense pas qu'ils
abandonnent les premières moi je n'aime
pas les primaires parce que c'est pas
notre culture
je voulais déjà dit ici un an ce n'est
pas notre culture nous à droite les
primaires ça veut dire que celui qui a
perdu fait des crocs-en-jambe aux autres
et donc c'est pas notre culture à gauche
et rassemblement ils le font à chaque
fois les mecs qui font 5% devienne
premier ministre
les mecs qui sont nuls d'une prison de
la république nous c'est pas notre
culture avec un type sortent du lot et
qu'on ne les embête pas avec des
crocs-en-jambe ou des conneries de
primaires nous c'est l'autre idée mais
si vous passez pour les primaires faire
plaisir h moules ou h moque genoux nadal
c'est juppé alors l'occurrence d'ong et
d'autres et d'autres sans ordonnance de
vias non mais là ce que fait alain juppé
en disant ça c'est qu'ils envoient un
signe à sarkozy du genre et bien si vous
aimez vous aurez plein air mais ne
pleurez pas après ne pleurez pas après
ou partie pour venise vous regrettez que
alain juppé n'est pas céder à la
tentation de venise la guerre oui un
petit peu c'est vrai oui pourquoi parce
que c'était très élégant de sa part de
le faire mais la tentation du canada
live aux jeunes atteints parce que
finalement non pas du tout pas du tout
s'il est élire son président et non
comme profil ne rassembleur
d'emblée on pense la crédibilité de
juppé pour rassembler la droite une
partie du centre et va plus de soi que
l'image que donne nicolas sarkozy que
vous vous le savez bien
aujourd'hui les prescrivant les arrivées
encore hier soir
depuis hier soir vous allez voir ce
qu'est nicolas sarkozy en campagne
moi c'est 25 ans que je le pratique je
sais comment ça se passe je rentre dans
son bureau
mes idées je ressors avec les siennes et
je m'en veux on les emmerde je réduire
ça donc il n'a pas toujours raison
m'est arrivé d'avoir des petits conflits
avec lui mais il se trouve que là je
pense qu'il a raison le vide le vide
qu'est mini écuries qui sont là pour
essayer de remplacer l'opposition
n'existe pas et d'ailleurs je pense que
les centristes ont tort de s'inquiéter
parce que l'idée de nicolas sarkozy
c'est pas de faire une opa agressives
sur les centristes pas du tout nos pères
amical alors si l'opa amicale
c'est à dire avec l'ong de gens qui
m'ont téléphoné hier soir pendant
l'émission après l'émission montre que
les centristes seront d'accord sur
quelque chose d'élégant présenter un
candidat parce qu'il ya quand même un
gros risque
le seul qui a fait chuter le pen en 2007
c'est sarkozy dise le pen 31 sarkozy
d'accord enfin plus rappelé le score de
2012 après 5 ans de canal nicolas
sarkozy mais pas à pelé le sas tournée
et non mais plus que vous m'avez
nécessité on laisse le soin de faire
sauver l'honneur mais bon on est ciblé
quand on fait 5 ans mais là ces balles
neuves
il n'est pas 100 ans balles neuves et je
pense qu'il nous faut un candidat qui au
premier tour face un très beau score
pour affronter la personne quelle
qu'elle soit il était ciblé lui dans sa
deuxième élection
j'en trouvais le bichonne le beh marine
le pen ait fait un score historique pour
le front national à l'élection
présidentielle après 5 ans de mandat
nicolas sarkozy est indéniable vous
pouvez pas sauter cette étape pour
rappeler qu'en 2007 il avait siphonné
les voix du front national
célia qui s'est passé quelque chose
c'est à dire que le rempart qu'il était
quant au front national si on veut
parler de rampes à eybens en 2012 il y
était plus remparts il était bleu
remparts c'est comme hollande qui est
élu c'est pas manqué de le pen
bon donc cette fois ci je pense que nous
nous parlons aujourd'hui michel fils que
de la présidence de l'ump
ah oui c'est vrai j'avais oublié c'est
souvent d'ailleurs que quand il ya une
personnalité politique qui eux il se
porte candidate à la présidence d'un
parti il ya quarante minutes sur service
public qui lui a offert seulement on a
eu tellement de conférence de presse
d'annoncés gouvernementales c'est à dire
dans la semaine comme vous pouvez quand
même rattrapé sur le 40 minutes à la
conférence de presse excusez du peu
c'était le président de la république
comme au lit et ça fait combien
d'audience un peu lassé et le nom mais
ces deux là auront coûté il ya d'une
querelle de chiffres puisque sarkozy a
fait lui il faut pas plus que le
président de la république
c'est donc il ya un problème dans ce
pays et vous voyez ça con qu'on prête à
nicolas sarkozy puisqu'il a
immédiatement comptabilisés les like sur
facebook
ça c'est la preuve qu'il n'a absolument
pas changé c'est à dire que voilà c'est
la même mécanique de challenge oui même
ou qu'on n'aime pas ça veut dire qu'à un
moment donné faut pas lui faire perdre
du temps mais il aurait changé tous
attendent vous avez donc je suis
d'accord et vous savez quoi je suis pas
son conseiller en com mais non vous vous
avez plus de moi je souhaite qu'ils ne
changent pas longtemps mais je le
souhaite qu'ils ne changent pas j'ai
revu un homme la semaine dernière qu'ils
étaient eux mêmes qu'en 2007 avec
l'appétit avec la forme avec l'envi avec
la générosité qu'il avait à donner
quelques et sur l'intérêt d'environ ce
bastringue
quel est son intérêt franchement de
revenir aujourd'hui alors un peu de
vanille monstrueux au sein de l'ump au
sein de l'opposition parce que lui dit
depuis le départ de borloo si bien
gentil enfin plic ploc foot passe en
train de se bat pour savoir qu'il est de
prison lui on s'en fout c'est pas ça le
problème
alors raison d'être d'anticiper sur le
reste c'est ce qui risque de faire soit
la raison d'être de ces primaires c'est
de les ouvrir à nos partenaires du
centre pour qu'il n'y ait qu'un seul
candidat à la présidentielle de 2017
c'est un entretien d'alain juppé à
paraître demain dans sud ouest
ça veut dire que si juppé veut à une
sorte de établir un rapport de force sur
la question des primaires vous céder le
terrain tout de suite et vous dites ok
il veut les primaires il y aura les
primaires ou pas - c'est déjà ne suis
pas partisan des primaires joué 10
années notre culture mais s'il faut les
primaires durée des primaires
c'est parce que monsieur b en même temps
ça va l'énervé à sa décharge ip que mes
roulés choisir non pas ce qui est aussi
une idée qui n'est pas bayroutistes si
j'ose dire et à partir le zoo vous
voulez dire que se décide à un axe juppé
bayrou d'un côté et nicolas sarkozy et
beaucoup d'autres sortes qui sait les
raisons du monde de dury le reste du
monde doit tellement d'accord d'ici
regarder les sondages
non il s'agit de la politique au sein
des deux cent soixante huit mille
adhérents de l'ump
pour l'instant il est à 80 6% voilà ça
dure deux mois et demi un peu de
patience
ensuite on verra qui gagne mais les
adversaires sont loyaux des adversaires
sont généreux eux aussi voilà le maire
mike o c'est formidable
il peut pas une erreur d'autres choses
parce que on arrive au terme mais c'est
très bien comme ça alors pour nicolas
sarkozy quel adversaire difficile à
avaler mais qui d'autre
les autres ne veulent pas y aller s'ils
n'y vont pas c'est qu'il ya un petit
problème parce qu'il se doutait qu'il
allait se passer quelque chose
il se passe quelque chose oui il est là
voilà il est de retour
c'est pas la pression et ça y ressemble
un quidam vous avez très envie de
chanter d'ajaccio l'enfant prodigue de
la gloire c'est ça le texte des paroles
marine le pen a déclaré qu'il n'avait
pas changé que c'était tant mieux que
c'était quand bennie pour elle c'est
formidable qu'elle dit ça parce qu'à
chaque fois que nicolas sarkozy arrive
le fonds national baisse parce que les
gens égarés hébété le front national
n'est pas un parti de gouvernement
c'est à partir de détournement et à
partir de ce moment là je pense que nous
allons récupérer les gens qui sont
partis égarés à au front national
présent avec nous parce qu'il sait déçu
par tous on n'a pas fait tout ce qu'on
avait dit qu'on devrait faire on ne l'a
pas fait c'est vrai on est une petite
crise entre temps bon by the way mais
comme disent les intellectuels mais mais
franchement c c est de retour et c'est
un bonheur que devant ils étaient
tranquilles ils étaient peinard il était
heureux
ils avaient tous et ben non il revient
je trouve qu'ils aient de responsabilité
chez lui qui est tout à fait honorable
et qu'on doit saluer ont d'ailleurs vous
verrez qu'on va la sauver
prochainement le les thèmes du meeting à
venir vous inquiète assez proche de lui
ça va on va peut-être en savoir un peu
plus sur des grandes villes
de son programme où c'est encore trop
tôt c'est un peu trop tôt on va
commencer par un je dis allez dans le
nord une terre compliqué à la sphère
socialiste edmond est monté front
national c'est au coeur jala à deux pas
de la maison du général de gaulle mal au
delà ou daubresse avait lancé de l'ump
tous les symboles sont là au carré vous
avez vu j'ai bien révisé
sauf la longue marche la longue marche
qui était évoquée hier de mao tsé toung
a duré un an octobre de 30 5 octobre
si j'ai pu l'aider à gérer ça dure et là
ça a duré l'asvel à 7,33 moi c'est un
peu différent c'est plus haut il ya eu
cent mille morts pendant la longue
marche
mais là ça sera pas tout à fait le cas
l'enor à quelques-uns l'ump revenant
symbole et saint bonnet ce qu'il a fait
hier c'est tendre la main pas du tout
toute la ville est sale et 3000 façon de
tendre la main et normands 2 ou sur un
sarkozyste est un peu ça l'idée
merci beaucoup pierre charon en tout cas
on a peu de doute sur la permanence de
votre sarkozysme à vous allez de la
musique après tout ça et c'est karine
deshayes que je vais recevoir la mezzo
soprano qui interprète une délicieuse
rosine dans le barbier de séville à
l'opéra bastille